how did the seals deal with fatigue
soreness and beat down and the beat down
of buds and sqt
without getting injured well you just
get used to it and again you know I say
this all the time buds and the sqt which
is the kind of the initial training
after you get done with buds which is
the basic underwater demolition SEAL
training that's a short part of your
career I mean it's literally a fraction
of your career it means nothing but just
like any working out you get used to it
and if it's like when you workout when
you if you haven't worked out for a long
time or someone that's someone that just
starts working out from nowhere never
worked out before they're gonna be sore
as hell when they first workout I just
had this happen to me cuz I got I want I
went on the road I went on a road trip
multiple back-to-back road trips and I
went overseas came back when I came back
I got sick so I was for like three weeks
I hadn't squatted heavy at all I had no
body all I did was bodyweight squats you
know pistols just lunges you know that's
how I work my legs there's just no
weight so you just do what you can do in
a hotel room in some strange part of
Europe and when I came back I was all
happy and I got on that squat once I
then I was sick and then once I got done
being sick I finally felt good I got
back on that squat rack and man my legs
were destroyed for four or five days I'm
talking you know having a hard time
sitting down having a hard time standing
up it was gnarly and but but that's just
because my body just it just wasn't he
lost that element so of course if you
just started working out in your walking
around sore all the time that's that's
that's because you got to get used to it
and in Budds you do get injured just
because it's massively repetition you
know there was a guy that we had that
was a trainer an athletic trainer for a
professional sports team and
when he was there there's a great
example there's something called patella
femoral syndrome which is when your
patella because of the way you're
running it rubs on your your femur and
it becomes problematic and he said in
like a whole season in the NFL or he
would see maybe one of those injuries
maybe two and you'll have to figure out
what it is and when he was working in
buds he would literally see 30 of those
a week so you just get to see I mean
there's more people there's ten times
the people but it's still a massive
amount of injuries and it's the same
thing in the SEAL Teams and the SEAL
Teams it's your shoulders it's your
backs
it's your knees it's your ankles you get
abused and it's it's it's not the
working out that does it to you it's not
working out it's carrying a guy on your
shoulder the over the rocky terrain out
in the desert and tripping on an ankle
that's what you can hurt it's jumping
over all off of a wall and you land on a
cinder block that breaks and you put you
know it's that's the kind of stuff but
working out doesn't really do it to you
I actually Wow one of the things when
when I was at asking the commander and
we were going through land warfare
training and I would work out every day
and I would roll with guys like teach
them some jujitsu and then roll with
them and I would you know guys are
because you know we're working hard
during the day or during the night and I
was kind of making fun of some guys that
were taking motrin and I was like you
don't need that you're weak and stuff
like that and sure enough right after we
got done I got something called bursitis
in my elbow because in land warfare your
constant getting down as you're crawling
you're and then I was in jujitsu on the
mat and I just banged it a couple times
and sure enough my elbow swelled up and
I had to take motrin
yeah don't don't open your mouth Jocko
yeah just keep it to yourself so you
know and again I was I was hammering
guys but in a joking manner and so they
hammered me right back when I had the
the motrin pills to try and heal that up
but it is like I said it's the it's the
the injuries come from not from working
out in fact I always think that the
working out prevents the injuries you
know that I think that's true with
everything I think that's true with
jiu-jitsu I think that's true with life
you you work out your strong your joints
are strong you your muscle density is
better your I mean just just work out
because it'll prevent injuries more than
it more than I don't worry about I look
at working out not as injuries gonna
happen I look at working out as injury
prevention and the last thing is you
shouldn't need to like completely crush
yourself every day in your workouts I
mean you shouldn't be going to a point
that you have massive muscle soreness
over your whole body or over even body
parts you don't need to do that you
don't need to do that you know do you
want to push yourself yeah you want to
push yourself but you want to be so sore
that you ache like can't perform your
job and also I like you know active rest
you know I hardly ever just do nothing
occasionally I will occasionally house
men on broke down yeah
and just eat steak and just chill but uh
but I like to do the active rest you
know I like to do some kind of jog swim
surf whatever and you know actually
jujitsu like if I have a sore back
I love getting on the mat it just
loosens everything up feels so good
but that's only at a certain level yeah
because when you're a white belt or a
blue belt or whole purple belt been that
brilliant it's just a battle you're
you're getting off the mats or I don't
get off the mats or 4G too seldom Seldon
do I get off the mat like man I'm tired
I mean we trained today I'm not that was
a no factor you know the name is just oh
yeah we trained but you know if you get
into the takedown that element though
that yeah yeah it'll be hard on your
back but even the takedown elements you
know if you're just gonna do pure
takedowns yeah but I mean it takedowns
gonna last how long and if your back
sore
bullguard and work something else yeah
so that's it in the bottom line is you
work out you do some of these workouts
you'll get used to it you'll get in the
zone and then you won't be so sore all
the time yeah that as an advocate of
rest I that's important that part where
you're like don't beat your down
yourself down because the exercise that
technically really split hairs here the
exercise doesn't make you stronger the
recovery from the exercise is when you
get stronger so yeah that was part of
the whole system it makes it strong but
when you recover from that exercise
that's when you're stronger I'll give
you them so yeah but the workout itself
is what induces the recovery so sure yes
there you go you well I guess so it's
all kinds of different philosophies
right different approaches like you you
prefer the active rest and that going
hard every day some people they prefer
go hard every day but then they'll have
a straight up to three days off that's
completely you know um but yeah you know
recovery from the exercise that's that's
the ticket yeah and when I say go hard I
mean like the muscular you know destroy
like if you can do squats until you
can't walk you can't do that alright
yeah you don't need to right you need to
initiate the growth mmm you don't need
to destroy them and and you can do you
know you can put with them with the
metabolic conditioning you could really
can destroy yourself a lot more often
and if you're doing it right you
shouldn't really be getting muscular
LeSueur from your metabolic condition if
you're doing it right yeah but then
again isn't that really a spectrum as
well it is ii can be like a heavier you
can I get quickly that's the that's the
beauty of workout that's why you should
never get bored with working out she can
change though